do you remember a time when you felt
hormonal and moody your skin was
breaking out your body was growing in
strange places and very fast and at the
same time people were expecting you to
be grown up in this new way teenagers
right well these same changes happen to
a woman when she's having a baby and we
know that it's normal for teenagers to
feel all over the place so why don't we
talk about pregnancy in the same way
there are entire text books written
about the developmental arc of
adolescents and we don't even have a
word to describe the transition to
motherhood
we need one I'm a psychiatrist who works
with pregnant and postpartum women a
reproductive psychiatrist and in the
decade that I've been working in this
field I've noticed a pattern it goes
something like this a woman calls me up
she's just had a baby and she's
concerned she says I'm not good at this
I'm not enjoying this do I have
postpartum depression so I go through
the symptoms of that diagnosis and it's
clear to me that she's not clinically
depressed and I tell her that but she
isn't reassured it isn't supposed to
feel like this she insists so I say okay
what did you expect it to feel like she
says I thought motherhood would make me
feel whole and happy I thought my
instincts would naturally tell me what
to do I thought I'd always want to put
the baby first this this is an
unrealistic expectation of what the
transition to motherhood feels like and
it wasn't just her I was getting calls
with questions like this from hundreds
of women all concerned that something
was wrong because they couldn't measure
up and I didn't know how to help them
because telling them that they weren't
sick wasn't making them feel better I
wanted to find a way to normalize this
transition
to explain that discomfort is not always
the same thing as disease so I set out
to learn more about the psychology of
motherhood but there actually wasn't
much in the medical textbooks because
doctors mostly write about disease so I
turned to anthropology and it took me
two years but in an out-of-print essay
written in 1973 by Dana Raphael I
finally found a helpful way to frame
this conversation mattre sense it's not
a coincidence that matter essence sounds
like adolescents both are times when
body morphing and hormone shifting lead
to an upheaval in how a person feels
emotionally and how they fit into the
world and like adolescents Metra sense
is not a disease but since it's not in
the medical vocabulary since doctors
aren't educating people about it it's
being confused with a more serious
condition called postpartum depression
I've been building on the anthropology
literature and have been talking about
mattress ins with my patients using a
concept called the push and pull here's
the pull part so as humans our babies
are uniquely dependent unlike other
animals our babies can't walk they can't
feed themselves they're very hard to
take care of so evolution has helped us
out with this hormone called oxytocin
it's released around childbirth and also
during skin-to-skin touch so it rises
even if you didn't give birth to the
baby
oxytocin helps a human mother's brain
zoom in pulling her attention in so that
the baby is now at the center of her
world but at the same time her mind her
mind is pushing away because she
remembers there are all these other
parts to her identity other
relationships her work hobby is a
spiritual and intellectual life not to
mention physical needs to sleep to eat
to exercise to have sex to go to the
bathroom
alone if possible this is the emotional
tug-of-war of mattress ins this is the
tension the women calling me were
feeling it's why they thought they were
sick if women understood the natural
progression of mattress ins if they knew
that most people found it hard to live
inside this push and pull if they knew
that under these circumstances
ambivalence was normal and nothing to be
ashamed of they would feel less alone
they would feel less stigmatized and I
think it would even reduce rates of
postpartum depression
I'd love to study that one day I'm a
believer in talk therapy so if we're
gonna change the way our culture
understands this transition to
motherhood women need to be talking to
each other not just me so mothers talk
about your Metra sense with other
mothers with your friends and if you
have one with your partner so that they
can understand their own transition and
better support you but it's not just
about protecting your relationship when
you preserve a separate part of your
identity you're also leaving room for
your child to develop their own when a
baby is born so is a mother
each unsteady in their own way
mattress ins is profound but it's also
hard and that's what makes it human
thank you
[Applause]